house cameras my name is peter pan we're
gonna play this [ __ ] godforsaken
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
this game I hate everything about this
game I hate everything I just want to go
home and cry can I not do that he's
gonna come he's gonna come [ __ ] you in
the ass you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate you why did I die
why so dumb
everything is dumb I'm sommore it now
it's lagging too I don't want to it's
like I have to do all this [ __ ] just
because his [ __ ] legs [ __ ] me I hate
everything my soul is forever lost
why don't you dare your [ __ ] legs
aren't gonna [ __ ] anyone anymore that's
right [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] clown
ass [ __ ]
ah the penis I have so much hate for
everything
Edgar's licking my fingers he can taste
my [ __ ] saltiness cuz I am [ __ ]
salty right now I know how to play with
you you [ __ ] well [ __ ] me maybe I
didn't get all the bananas go up go your
heart that often
well [ __ ] keeps calling me on skype
yeah [ __ ] down there
ah no big deal ah I hate this part
it's not gay if you like it
wait where to go oh there he is of
course okay I got two bananas I got two
bananas up my ass I love bananas up my
ass let's get real here [ __ ] go up what
are you doing huh I can't I give up you
win